foreign
Spokane Washington what's up Laura
um doing well how are you I'm great life
all right y'all doing okay
um yeah shaking a little bit
oh good grief don't don't be shaking
I've got my feet on the ground I'm
taking deep breaths there you go perfect
perfect yeah what's up how can I help
so um
um my question is uh something I've been
struggling with for a decade now which
is I'm homesick for Hawaii
and
um a lot of people in my family
experience the same thing
um and I've been trying to handle it by
getting in touch with my community here
and just
you know uh sort of hustling to get
into the community and make friends and
uh it's difficult
here and there
um but the homesickness
it'll it'll set me into just depression
for on weekends at a time
um you've been feeling it for a decade
huh
yeah
all right I'm gonna ask you a crazy
question about homesickness okay
okay it's about 10 years ago how old are
you now
30. okay oh man perfect so tell me about
20 year old Laura who was she what was
she gonna be when she grew up what does
she want to do tell me about her
beautiful was she crazy when she always
making out with everybody like tell me
all about Laura oh my gosh no yeah
[Laughter]
um a 20 year old Laura moved to San
Francisco okay uh uh because she had a
dream of working in the film industry
okay which is something that didn't
exist essentially where it came from
um
it's kind of known if you want to get
education you go to the mainland you go
seek it out and everyone said you can
always come back
but it's unaffordable
okay it's um practically impossible
um tell me about 18 year old Laura
18.
um
oh gosh
so uh 18 year old Laura was
uh jumping into freshwater pools
uh going to the beach
uh having fun with all my buddies uh
just family
family surrounded by Family his
grandparents um cousins brothers sisters
yep
um and uh my immediate family has all
moved with me along the way
except for my grandparents who are still
there
um and uh they always say that they're
the abandoned grandparents of course
grandparents are wonderful
um
um passport agents for guilt trips
yeah they're wonderful at that everybody
was born there exactly
two yeah
um most of the time
not always now let's I want to
categorize it like you're talking about
Hawaii okay so yeah
it's the most beautiful place on planet
Earth
can we agree on that
yes I was just hanging out with my
friends this weekend and they are from
Hawaii and just listening to them
discuss it it sounds magic I've never
been it sounds not real
okay everything not real from like the
cleanliness of the air in certain parts
of the certain Islands to the PACE
everyone's just kind of a notch slower
to the food is so fresh like it was
swimming this morning and we're eating
it tonight like all of it to D family
Roots like he was explaining to me how
this
this part of the family came over from
Japan this part
like
I want you to know leaving that is very
very real okay
okay that's that's number one you're not
crazy
the second thing is a more general
statement of when I hear people talk
about their homesick they miss what
they're often telling me is they miss
the person they were before they left
ah I see and the environment was a
context but often so was the age
when you said 20 I was like yep
one of the coolest guys ever was 18 to
20 year old John that guy ruled because
he thought he ruled he was an idiot like
a punk skinny but he thought he
was awesome
and the rules didn't apply and he could
jump in pools and be silly and go on
dates that and so I'm homesickness for
I'm homesick for him in his Carefree
attitude in the possibilities that were
endless ahead of me
and I always think if I just go back to
that town and that place where I was I
can reclaim that and it never works out
because yeah because my John in his 40s
he goes with him
and that guy's tired has two kids been
married a long time you know you know
what I mean it's just it's it doesn't
like my hair I don't like my haircut
like it's just it's just the same right
that guy that guy goes with me
yeah
and so my question for you is
do you miss Hawaii do you miss your
family roots and do you have this deep
call to get back to
um like a family Legacy that can be very
very real
and or
man do you miss that Laura that a whole
world was possibilities and you were
gonna go make it in the film that you
were gonna be the one that got out and
went and did this wild stuff on the
mainland and then brought all this money
enjoy and excitement Fame back and now
your 30 year old Laura and you're like
got a job you got insurance right it's
yeah you missed that person is that what
it is
see
at home during the day take care of them
and the chores and then go to work and
uh serve uh a lot of people had to bring
their uh their problems to me too
so is there is there a sense that in
some ways now especially with two
toddlers And especially with your
service job
you're living somebody else's life
yeah it feels like that sometimes
I bet it feels like that a lot I don't
want to tell you how you're feeling but
I bet if you were honest with yourself
it would most of your days spent making
sure everyone else's life is okay
yeah actually the other night I said
um you know if I wanted to work in
Hospitality I would have stayed on the
island
because you can make a hundred you know
a table a night yeah your tips would
have been way more right yeah yeah
here's what here's a third even wackier
on top of these two layers that I've
given you a third one
um it wasn't until like within a hundred
years
and especially it wasn't in until like
the last I don't know 30 or 40 maybe 50
years
that there were cameras everywhere and
videos everywhere and our brains have
some really remarkable built-in
um ways of slowly letting memories fade
and they take they move into our bodies
and they're not so acute and not so
painful we remember how we felt on the
beach but we don't remember like the
exact whatever they look like right
and now we have bypassed that and we go
back to it and go back to it and go back
to it we scan we scan we scan we look at
all photos we look at all photos we look
at old videos we look at new photos at
new videos we see you see new 18 year
old Laura's running around on Hawaii and
you remember you
you see what I'm saying so we've kind of
hacked our brains natural way of moving
on from heartache and from memories and
we keep dragging our our brain back
through the mud and be like yeah but
remember this and we keep bringing it
back up and it doesn't know what to do
because this is new technology right and
so we have all three of these things
here's my question for you
when's the last time you asked yourself
with with true honesty
what do I actually want with my one tiny
precious little life
I've been thinking about that a lot
lately lately
yeah
um I'm gonna tell you this and running
to a location probably won't give that
to you
okay it might it might maybe let me be
super clear it might
changing environments may be exactly
what you need
but my guess is uh or what I promise you
is if you pack up right today and you
move to Hawaii tomorrow and I gave you a
million dollars and you just you had no
money worries
30 year old Laura would go back to the
island
with your frustrations with your I
haven't grieved over the fact that I was
going to make it in the industry and I
got two little toddlers not a bad life a
great life in fact but just different
not what I not how I drew it up
I have to remind myself that on occasion
because it was not
I'm a freaking YouTuber now Laura that's
my job that's my job I was never in the
cards that wasn't the plan and here we
are right so sometimes I wanted to be I
was gonna be a college president that
was gonna be what I did and sometimes I
have to remind myself I I intentionally
chose a different track I went a
different way
and it's my life's gonna look very
different than it did and it's all good
it's all good it's gonna look different
right
so you've been asking yourself the
question what do you want
and I think
I think
I'm going in a positive direction
because I'm
I'm hustling really hard to get into
um
to helping others get their films made
out here oh my gosh you're the most
pragmatic mother of two stop being
pragmatist for a second what do you want
to do Laura
fast forward 36 months 36 months it's
very it's a blink of an eye
three years 36 months fast forward me
there where do you want to be what do
you want to be doing
okay that's that's a really tough
question no you have it right when I
said it it came right to you you know
exactly where you want to be you just
don't want to say it out loud because
you've said it before and it didn't work
out where do you want to be
helping my community
oh my gosh it feels I I feel like I want
I want Community I want more community
you want friends you want neighbors what
does that mean what does community mean
be very specific
um
a Dungeons and Dragons group okay okay I
knew it you're kind of weird and you got
to be able to say that out loud
yeah
actually yeah it's really funny
um it's not funny I mean I
I'm
I'm a weirdo yeah we all be a weirdo I
like to get together with my buddies and
watch grown men punch each other in the
face for money I like we watch fights
all the like that's insane it's dumb
that we do that and I do it every week I
do it all the time this weekend I'm
going to see a punk rock show I'm in my
40s I'm too old for this I'm going
anyway and I'm probably gonna get hurt
just like I did last time and it will be
worth like we're all weird and you look
like that is right on that is right on
the level with me I am like punk rock
show sounds awesome and then right after
the show you're gonna sit down and look
at cards about like Wizards and and
swords and stuff and Sparkle thing I
don't know what they I don't understand
yeah but here's the deal
um I got a a great friend named Wes and
he's from the island
and he cooks incredible dishes oh yeah
you know whose house I never say no to
when they invite me to dinner
my friend West
a hundred percent of the time he's asked
me dinner I go
does he give you malasadas I don't even
know what that means but he gives me
lots of delicious things I don't even
know I don't ask as many questions so
here's the thing
if you started a weekly Dungeons and
Dragons group and you said I'm offering
food
are you are you are you married
I am okay if you told husband hey we're
gonna start putting some money in the
budget because we're gonna start having
people over and you might have to find
things to do in fact I need you to take
care of the kids because once a week I'm
putting on my uh wizard Warrior hat I
don't know what you wear to play Dragons
I'm putting on my cape and uh we're
getting weird we're gonna get super
weird up in here in this house and I'm
making some great Hawaiian food and I'm
having people over within six months you
would have a gang that would go to real
war with you not just Dungeons and
Dragons war
but you have to be intentional about
creating the life that you want to have
and then there's going to come a moment
when Laura who loves who she has become
in whatever environment she is in
might want to go back to Hawaii great
or might be completely at peace just
visiting Hawaii
see what I'm saying
yes
what's holding you back from creating a
whole new world where you are
time
you got two Knuckleheads that's for sure
what else
[Music]
I
fear probably too yeah
yeah let me tell you this the greatest
the the greatest gift you can give your
kids is your presence
the second greatest gift you can give
your kids is you go be well
and you go hang out with friends
and you sit down with your husband and
say we have two little ones our marriage
is different now and I want a
rambunctious fun wild weird Dungeons and
Dragons life
I want a great sex life again I want to
be crazy and silly again I want all that
stuff again and we're gonna have to
figure out how to do that
because you keep thinking back to when I
was 18 when I was 19 and the world was
standing before me and I want to tell
you at 30 the world is still standing
right in front of you
okay
it's just a little weirder now
definitely weirder you got two kids
right
and your husband does his accounting job
or whatever he's I got who knows what
he's doing but it's just different now
but the world is still standing right in
front of you
and you get one shot you get one
opportunity and I sound like Eminem
right now you get one path that's it
you get one go
and it's easy you're at a you're at a
crossroads right now Laura that I hear
over and over and over and over you get
two kids you're married you just find
yourself doing the same thing over and
over again suddenly you're gonna blink
you're gonna be 43.
and you can either be 43 with some young
teenage kids who are always rolling
their eyes because their mom is so fun
and silly and goofy and holds them
accountable
and her and dad are always closing the
door in the middle of the afternoon and
being all weird and turning the music up
God knows what they're doing in there
because that's the kind of house we have
or you can have a husband who's a
roommate kids who are just staring at
their screens in the room you get to
choose the life you get to choose it
you get to choose it
you are worth that choice you're worth
that choice you're worth that choice
it's gonna be an adventure moving
forward Laura you're worth every penny
of it take your husband out for
breakfast this week and said hey I
talked to this uh goofball on a podcast
and everything's about to be different
around here hope you'll join me